hello we hope you found this course to
be enjoyable and rewarding now that
we're wrapping up your thoughts might be
turning to how you can build on what
you've learned to conduct original
research to develop new technologies and
so much more
the material should position you really
well to do this the models for word
representations that we discussed are
likely to be valuable components for any
task you take on our relation extraction
unit focused on powerful techniques for
distance supervision which is a really
common mode for applied problems
and the natural language inference unit
is representative of the kind of
opportunities and challenges one faces
when building deep learning systems with
really large data sets
and of course the other lectures
highlight more diverse application areas
and help reveal how even complex cutting
edge models are actually usually made up
of familiar modular components
and of course by now you've done a lot
of work with our notebooks you've
designed three original systems and
entered them into bake offs and you've
completed an original project this is an
unusually high level of hands-on work
and the practical skills you've acquired
should serve you well in many domains
the field of nlu continues to progress
rapidly and you're now extremely well
positioned to follow those changes and
even help to shape them for our part
we'll continue to update and improve our
nlu course materials and share them
widely and we hope to see you in a
future stanford class soon
you